Cookie dough ice cream was always my first choice when I was younger,
but since I'm not able to find one with healthy ingredients,
I like to make my own. I find that many people are shocked
when they find out what it takes to make ice cream.
This ice cream maker attachment is a must.
I pour my raw, uncooked ingredients into a frozen bowl as it turns
and within 20 minutes I have thick
yet soft vanilla ice cream with an orange hue.
Thanks to my pasture raised chickens,
I let that firm up in the freezer
and then freshly mill my regeneratively grown flour.
I want my kids to know what a true
cookie dough ice cream experience tastes like,
so this is an important part.
Combine my wet ingredients melted butter,
egg, vanilla,
and four tablespoons of coconut sugar with my dry ingredients
whole grain flour, baking soda,
and unrefined salt. Lastly,
I massage coarsely chopped
good ingredient chocolate chunks into my cookie dough,
making little cookie balls
that I organize on a Parchment lined baking sheet.
This is put in the freezer for a short while
and then I store them in a jar until they are ready to be.
This is homemade ice cream,
so it requires some extra time to soften up on the counter
before scooping. There's no gums or stabilizers.
One or two scoops per bowl
topped with fresh cookie dough brings me back to my childhood
and it makes me So happy that my kids have a healthy treat
that they can themselves make for the rest of their lives.